a tablet with an original price of $600
pause when I read a question and there's
lots information look as a whole
paragraph right whenever I come across
something that's an important piece of
information I know it's down right you
remember how I said oh my one of my big
tips for these was be verbal right and
explain what's going on so original
price 680 note it down let's keep moving
through it has 10% GST don't know what
GST stands for yeah well all most of us
here tonight goods and services tax so
here's our good an item right and the
government is taxing people through
quiet 10% they never do for a while Shh
it's then sold at an end-of-year sale
for 10% off okay so I have a whole bunch
of information here he comes the
question is the sale price sale price is
the sale price of the tablet more than
less than or equal to its original price
justify your answer by calculation now
what do your instincts told you I'm
actually going to do this like this
right returns there for a second
because if we went up number one it
would take a long time number two if
you're like me you'll like have an idea
and then you hear what someone else says
you'd be like ooh that was different to
my idea and she's really smart so I'm
just gonna bandwagon bit and change my
mind and say you know I think what maybe
so here's something to I want you all
know I'm gonna be would you make that I
want you all to think of an answer now
there were three options right more than
less than or equal to I want you to
think about what you reckon is totally
okay if what your idea your estimate is
ends up being different what we get
that's the whole point going to the
question and I'm gonna count to three
and I'm gonna ask you all to shout it
out at best
time you're either gonna say more than
equal or less than actually not shot
maybe just say it in your normal voice
especially so just is an extra tax so
let me give you the picture before I'll
ask you to save yourself price it gets
increased by 10 percent then it gets
decreased by 10 percent and that's the
sale price that gets sold to consumers
okay is this gonna be
option one more then option two less
then option three equal to the original
ready gun died in your head if you're
absolutely I'm sure just shut up okay
ready you can take one two three we will
I think we're all different everyone and
we got all three heads again say here we
go
he comes the power of mathematics
actually sold this question all right
penny hand pin in hand and follow with
me so here's where method to this other
way it really shines okay so watch with
me
I start with penny here I start with six
hundred and eighty okay I start with six
hundred eighty this is me trying to work
out the sale price the final sale price
now what happens is two things happen to
this original price
number one it increases right that was
this kind of question over here right so
to increase I multiply by something over
100 and it's increased so it's bigger
than 100 right it'd be a hundred ten
right you know it's like how did you get
put in a hundred ten percent right
that's 110 percent okay so there's the
first thing there's the GST if I don't
even gonna write that GST okay but then
that's the only thing that happens it
then subsequently gets decreased ten
percent off so now like this is the
taxed price and then I'm going to
discount it right so it's a decrease so
it's still multiplying by something over
100 but it'll be less than 100 why not
because it's decreased right it'll be
90 that's 10% off do you see that 10%
score so now before I actually calculate
this right because I could spin this
into my calculator I'm going to try and
work out what it is without a calculator
because then we can get some insight
here right so I've got 600 meaning okay
now what are these two we've seen this I
showed you how to write these as
decimals as well as fractions right 110
over 100 what's that as a decimal it's
one point one it's one point 190 over a
hundred what's that as a decimal not a
head tonight what 0.9 okay so now before
I get onto this 680 just figured out the
680 for a second what's going to happen
here what's gonna happen yeah I reach me
a calculator now punching it if you have
it already
what's one point one times zero point
nine who's got this just this - he's got
it he's got it times x times 0.99 now
that's this part over here right I'm
gonna put my 680 back I don't know what
it is yet we will in a second but you
don't need to know what it is to know
whether it's more than or equal all this
which one is it
it's less isn't it yes this is your
point nine time say that again slower 73
this in fact is what is this
this is 99% exactly of the original it's
less just less
okay sir there's an unsub but-but-but
what is the it's a mean three strangers
in it you add 10% and then you take away
10% but you don't end where you started
right look it's not a huge discrepancy
but it is a discrepancy does that make
sense